what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
talking about the latest developments in
the demon Slayers story we finally get
the long-awaited return of some of my
favorite characters so make sure to stay
tuned for that if you enjoy seeing these
weekly Demon Slayer videos make sure to
smash that like button to let me know if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you won't
know when new Demon Slayer videos drop
follow us on instagram @ and me up floor
where we regularly have boats for what
kind of demon server videos you want to
see next so if you want to help decide
what future videos I make make sure
you're following us there at anime
uproar linked in the description there
will be manga spoilers in this video we
are covering the latest developments
after all you've been warned now without
further ado let's jump into it we left
off last chapter where Tundra was said
to be as good as dead by Mouzon even
though Mouzon said it wouldn't happen I
suggest that that tundra might become a
demon that would help heal him from his
serious injuries while giving him an
Opie power boost as well besides it's
been established for a while that there
are bad demons and good demons like
Tamayo ushiro and Ezek oh the latter
three all helped fight against moves on
so tundra the man who's always been
super empathetic to demons could - and
remember this as Shonen and hundreds of
protagonists so muslim' has to be wrong
that tundra is dead for good so if he's
already wrong about one thing it's
possible he's wrong about tundra now
becoming a demon so that's where we left
off it was arguably the biggest
cliffhanger in the show and me to read
the love pillar and give you the water
pillar and igor the snake pillar had
their hands full fighting the demon king
of pop moves on himself this chapter
starts with something crazy right away
we seen as Zuko after all of these
chapters she's been asleep since we
found out that she could survive in the
Sun she was the first demon discovered
that could do that
that is why Mouzon wants to consume her
because he wants her immunity to the Sun
seemingly someone from the world of the
Dead reaches out to naisu Co to wake her
up since Tundra is in danger tendrils
dad also wore this type of clothing with
squares on it so it's possible that it
is him
we have gotten these moments before
where the family guides these two from
the afterlife so this isn't too
surprising mezack Oh finally wakes up
sweating all over the former water
pillar Sakura pseudo-code Aki is
watching over her and he surprised when
she wakes up he asks her what's wrong
but she starts running both the former
sound pillar and then Goku's dad see her
run by wondering where she's going
they tell kiria that she's run away and
asked about what they should do
kiria wonders what would be the best
course of action he wonders if she is
being manipulated by Mouzon or if the
medicine returned her to human but he
thinks both are unlikely if she had
turned into a human
the former water pillar would have been
able to catch her without a problem
he decides that they have to go after
her but then his father reaches out to
him from the afterlife telling him that
he can leave nez Zuko alone and that
she's alright it seems like family
members from the afterlife are the MVPs
of this chapter despite the protests of
his sister's kiria says that the let
Natsuko go because father said to leave
her alone
he has tears flowing down his eyes he's
clearly touched by the fact that his
father made contact we jumped and Ezek
oh who is as impressive as ever she's
running so fast as a quandary an
impressive demon slayer in his own right
can't keep up with her anymore
the ghost keeps guiding mezack Oh even
pointing her in the right direction
Mitsuko jumps off a gigantic cliff and
so kanji has to stop dead in his tracks
he thinks that the human medicine must
have been ineffective if she could jump
from such a height and survive mezu ko
keeps running panting as she goes she
still has those vampire teeth we
associated with demons but she's panting
hard like a human we'd then jump to time
judo he looks terrible the wound in his
right eye is spreading supposedly
destroying his flesh he starts crying
from his left eye showing that he's not
completely dead yet meanwhile the three
pillars Guillaume it slowly and agudo
are having an extremely tough time with
Mouzon Gill needs a new sword since this
current sword is broken
it appears he needs a breath of the
water sword specifically though because
he suggests that he'll need to find a
sword from one of the Fallen breath of
water swordsmen eager to us having his
own problems he can't help but notice
how fast moves on is and how he can take
on three people without even stop
to breathe then meet suti gets what
seems like a pretty deep cut above her
chest this cut is followed by
significant cuts on gu and even euros
head moves on is a killing machine
his limbs are moving like crazy
seemingly hitting everywhere at once the
craziest part is he looks completely
calm and hasn't even broken a sweat
Mouzon is impressed that Mitsui can
still move
she thinks that despite her wounds she
has to do everything she can to stop
Musa however she suddenly stops and
screams out in pain at this point in the
chapter it seems like this could be
exactly what happened to tons it off
meat so he could be going through the
initial phases of the same process Igor
was obviously worried he screams doubt
meets with his name remember he has
feelings for meet suti this must be
extremely painful for him to watch meet
suti tells him to just take care of
himself
please wash is about to get hit by one
of Moses attacks this would likely spell
the end for her but luckily Guillaume a
makes in the nick of time finally I was
waiting for go made the strongest Demon
Slayer to show up as was meat city in
the last few chapters this is why he
deserves the title goku of demon slayer
he arrived just when things seemed
hopeless and all of a sudden everyone
including us feels reassured not to
mention hyped even moves on his caught
off guard
Yomi apologizes for being late as Mitsui
hilariously cries in the background just
as moves on is thinking that gilma is
the demon hunter who took out kakushi
bow
someone starts to cut him vertically it
is big bro jerk with a heart of gold
himself sana me the wind pillar remember
kill me and sana me had red tinge blades
so their attacks can do more damage than
regular old blades the red pain suggests
the power of the Sun which is the
strongest breath and demon slayer and as
we all know the Sun is almost every
demons kryptonite sana me looks like a
complete boss here his blank expression
actually kind of reminds me of time
zeroes non-self state but he could just
be super serious about getting revenge
he succeeds in getting moves on to break
some bottles and then Sonny uses the
liquid housed inside the bottles to set
the demon king of Pop on fire Sunday
Me's always fill with these unique
fighting strategies like when he held a
sword with his foot and attack a cushy
bow with it for that reason I loved
watching his fight
you never know what he's gonna do next
so moves on experiences some burning
overall he's fine but he does have an
upset expression on his face showing
that son amis attack got to 'mentally
whenever you can get an enemy to lose
their composure in battle that's a
victory in its own right thence enemy
claims he'll kill moves on and insults
him as well in usual sanity style
remember if it wasn't for Mouzon son
amis little bro Kenya would still be
alive the death of Kenya the most
important person in Sunny's life is
still very fresh for him this more than
explains the hatred and killing intent
you can see in son amis expression he
definitely has the will to win and thus
complete his revenge we jump Tamura Tahu
spots moves on the enemy of the demon
slayer family Maratha is actually trying
to convince himself to try killing him
but that would be pretty pointless as we
know not even the combined attacks of
Pilar's have done much
luckily gu enters the picture before mu
rata does anything stupid
gu tells Morita that Angelo can move so
Mora Tasha treat his wounds in a safe
place again everyone has a role to play
even though every role is not fighting
moves on Bharata is touch the gear
remembered his name which is a nice
touch on the mangakas part it's so easy
for even the audience to forget what
quote-unquote extras are called however
here Gere remembers and in this way the
mangaka is training us to not overlook
anyone not only does everyone serve an
important purpose they deserve having
their names remember this idea is also
supported by the fact that kagaya
Ubu yashiki the highest ranking of the
demon Slayers at the time went out of
his way to learn everyone's name in the
organization you and I should follow
this example I'm totally the guy that
hears names and forgets them two seconds
later so I'll take notes from kaga and
give you and try to put more of a
conscious effort in remembering names
when I hear them again demon Slayers
giving us some important lessons and
tips for life it means a lot to people
when you show them that you care by
remembering and calling them by their
names we all love hearing the sounds of
our own names it means so much that it
even brings more etat to tears and tears
of joy always call for smashing that
like button if you haven't already mood
attack goes on to help tangelo as he's
carrying
he thinks about the fact that you and
him were in the selection together even
though there's an enormous strength gap
between you and Murata Buddha Tom
mentions that they have the same motives
pretty much everyone wants to help the
others and to stop the evil moves on
wants it for all no matter how strong it
is continually being emphasized that
everyone has a role to play much like in
life we need people to play their
different roles some are warriors
some are strategists some are healers
and the roles go on and on like
Shakespeare put it the world's a stage
and all of us are actors playing our own
roles even if one seems more glamorous
than another we all have vital roles to
play in life I really like that about
demons there that no matter how weak
characters are their lives can always
have meaning in the big picture of
things if they act with courage and
virtue Punto still looks terrible but
then we jump to this place with no smell
ton zero is in a place with a blue sky
he has an axe in his hand it seems like
he has suddenly jumped back to his old
life before all of the demon slayer
stuff happened he's even missing his
Demon Slayer mark I'm very curious about
what's going to come of this moment
obviously don't think they try to pull
off a everything up to this point was a
dream moment but they might pull a gooda
logon moment where tandro is shown a
peaceful blissful dream but needs to
reject it in order to face the harsh
reality of the situation he needs to
make a difference in the harsh world
rather than escaping into this
comforting fake one perhaps some
interesting characters like yo Deecee
the strongest demons there in history or
Tundras that family members will show up
and give him some important info at this
point this could even be construed as a
kind of limbo a kind of glimpse into
heaven where he doesn't need to worry
about fighting demons anymore
however there's no way dungeon of the
Shonan protagonist is going to die
especially not this early on let me know
what you think this place with no scent
is I wouldn't be surprised that time
zero comes out of it with some enhanced
powers that will make a difference
during what seems to be the final fight
of the series and that is it for today's
video thank you so much for watching if
you enjoy these weekly Demon Slayer
videos make sure to smash that like
button to let me know if you have and be
sure to sub
scribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell or you won't know when
the latest demon Surtur videos come out
follow us on instagram at enemy uproar
where we regularly have votes for what
kind of demon Surtur videos you want to
see next so if you want to help decide
what future videos I make make sure
you're following us there at anime
uproar once again leave your thoughts on
this chapter in the comments there's so
much stuff that needs to be answered
here and I think we can have some really
fruitful discussions below and let me
know if you're betting on Zenit winning
those case showing up in the next
chapter hashtag demon Slayers for life a
big thank you goes out to our patrons
over on patreon who help make videos
like this one possible I'm blown away by
the amount of patience we have and I'm
extremely thankful to each and every one
of you I especially want to thank our
pro hero to your patrons the one and
only Gilgamesh baby ray nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson kings I'll just $13
beat a Karachi and Anatoly Cassatt's key
DJ Nathaniel alpha deal and angel cruise
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans Stephen in
grata al-hola naught I'm Matty Mac 239
makoto-kun Seth Cooper and the world if
you enjoy our work you can support more
of it by going over to patreon.com slash
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as $1 if you do so you'll
get your name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access or
private patron only discord so check out
patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]
you